Now that you got the basic
structure of Rules down,
let's talk specifically
about validation rules.
Validation rules are primarily used for
enforcing the structure of your data and
the format of your content.
Take a look over here.
This is the start of
a validation rule for
a new value being written
in the listName field.
And in plain English what it's saying,
is that the value that's
written here must be a string.
And it's placement where it's
nested inside userLists and
then these two wildcard variables,
and the property name listName
makes it specifically a rule that
affects the listName values.
So let's take an actual
look at the variables and
methods that are used within
this expression itself.
First I'd like to point out
this variable called newData.
When you're writing your validation
rules, you're almost always going to
need a way to refer to the value
that is either currently there, or
that their users try to
write to that location.
Because of this,
the Firebase rules language provides two
predefined variables specifically for
these values.
And they are data and newData.
You can use these anywhere
within your rules.
Now data refers to the data
as it currently is, and
newData refers to the data
after a write has taken place.
In the rules language, these have
the variable types of RuleDataSnapshots.
And they're called DataSnapshots,
because they can either be a single
value or a whole portion of
data in the Firebase database.
So just to be explicit,
if I had a shopping list
with something like Lyla's List,
and then I went to edit it.
Lyla's List would be the current value,
which would be stored in data.
Awesome List.
Lyla's Awesome List, would be
the value that'd be stored in newData.
Now as I stated, both data and newData
are what's known as RuledDataSnapshots.
And RuledDataSnapshots have a bunch of
methods that you can use in the rules.
I'll go ahead and link to the API docs,
where you can read to your heart's
content about all of these methods.
But here are a couple of interest.
Because these are DataSnapshots,
which know their location in the tree.
You can use the parent or child method
to navigate to other nodes in the tree.
This let's you do cool things like create
rules that compare one of the database
to another part of the database.
For example, if you wanted to access
the owner value from your listName rule,
you could write newData.parent,
which would take you from
listName up to the parent here.
Then .child('owner'),
which would take you down to the owner.
Then finally val,
which is a method that let's you get
the current value at that variable.
And for
the user lylafish at this specific node,
this rule would return this value here.
And then you could use it in
something like a comparison.
In this case this is a kind of
silly validate rule that doesn't
make much sense.
It's saying that the newData
that you're writing for
the listName must be the same
as the owner's email.
So you'd have a bunch of
listNames named after owners.
But hopefully that gives a little
bit more insight about how you might
be able to use the parent or
child methods.
Note that the ability to use parent in
the rules is somewhat different than
the DataSnapshots that we've
been using in our Android app.
When you get a DataSnapshot
on the client side, you
can't see anything that is the parent
of the location that you requested.
In the rules though,
you can look at any other part of
the database in order to make a rule.
Which is why you can use
a method like parent.
Now as I mentioned,
you can use the value method,
and that'll give you a primitive value
back from a data or newData object.
In addition, you have methods that check
for the type at a current location.
And exist is actually a really helpful
method to use when you're writing rules
that are specific to whether
a value is being added or removed.
And with that, we can see that this
isString method here, is one of the type
method which is making sure that
the value stored in newData is a string.
Let's see an example of a little bit
of a more complicated rule here.
So here we've added another
little bit to this rule.
And basically what this says,
is that newData is both a string, and
that this new listName has at
least one character in it.
From this example,
you can see that JavaScript Logical and
Comparison Operators
are available to you.
In addition, when you're dealing
with values that are strings,
there's a subset of
Javascript string methods and
properties which are available to you.
newData.val().length is
one such example,
the length value is available to you.
And another helpful one
is the matches method,
which allows you to match a string
against a regular expression.
For example, if you wanted to validate
data at a location to see if it's in
the form of an email address, you could
use standard email address Regex.
And then use matches to
do the actual comparison.
So that's pretty much the summary of
writing a single validation rule.
In addition,
there are a few other things that
you might want to keep in mind.
The first is that whenever you write
server side validation rules, you should
also be writing the corresponding
client side validation rules.
For example,
in the dialog where somebody changes
a shopping lists listName, you should
go ahead and check that that listName's
actually greater than zero characters.
There's no sense wasting one
are your users' data plans,
by pinging the database with
improperly formatted data.
So go ahead and save them and
yourself that useless network traffic.
Second, remember that validation
rules are only checked
when you're actually writing data.
This maybe pretty straightforward, but
they're not checked when you read data.
And finally, validation rules are not
checked when you're deleting data,
otherwise you'd basically never be able
to remove anything from the database.
For example, if I try to set
a listName here to null, and
it was checking validation rules, then
it would complain that null is neither
a string nor
has a length greater than zero.
But it doesn't do those checks, and
instead you don't have any validation
checks when you're deleting something.
Okay, so now that you know
how to write a single rule,
let's talk about validating
an entire structure.